okay I'm gonna do something a little bit
different today I'm going to give you a
peek behind the curtain of political
talk shows and YouTube channels and blah
blah blah blah blah okay so the context
here is that there are lots of
right-wingers who do shows on the radio
on the internet on YouTube whom I
disagree with politically really
significantly like I have real serious
disagreements with a lot of these
right-wingers but when I've met them in
person most of them are pretty normal
like in private conversations most
right-wingers aren't doing material
they're not reciting talking points
they're respectful they have friendly
conversation and I've given a bunch of
examples Alex Jones now he seems to be
completely off the rails but when I met
Alex Jones he actually seemed like he
sort of acknowledged that he was playing
a character on his show he had a
completely normal conversation with the
hosts of free talk live which is a
libertarian radio show and I was sort of
in this circle of four people and he was
a totally respectful nice sort of normal
guy now this may have changed this was
like eight years ago
Sean Hannity Sean Hannity's politics are
disgusting but he was one of the nicest
people at a talk radio conference that I
went two years ago he took pic took
pictures with everyone liberal hosts
conservative hosts nice to everybody
approachable etc etc more recently I met
roaming millennial who is a young a
conservative youtuber person at
politican in Los Angeles
I met that Kyle khushu kid who is like a
pro-gun guy from the Parkland High
School shooting I know he's an extreme
right-wing or we vehemently disagree on
everything but he was respectful he was
nice he came up to me he said he's aware
of my channel etc etc like not even a
hint that people are going to start
being rude in person behind the scenes
like when there's no reason to do it for
your audience this gets us to right-wing
conspiracy youtuber mark Dice now I
don't know if you've heard of Mike mark
dice and if you haven't maybe you won't
find this interesting and I apologize in
that case
but it is a sort of like I said peek
behind the curtain I've never done
something like this so let's see what
people think he has a big YouTube
following more than a million
subscribers and I previously had only
one interaction with mark Dice which is
when YouTube's ad pocalypse was going on
and his channel was getting crushed and
my channel was getting crushed we had a
brief Skype call and we were just
talking about how bad have you been hit
what can we do do you have a youtube
contact we can talk to seemed completely
sort of normal and respectful in his
private interactions few days ago I get
a Twitter direct message from him and he
says to me I'm curious what your honest
unbiased opinion of the situation is is
Wikipedia being unfair I do mention you
in the presentation nothing against your
success just an honest comparison and he
links me to a video and I check out the
video and you can look at the video
yourself and what he's essentially
saying in this video is that he believes
there is an anti conservative bias on
Wikipedia that editors are blocking
details about his career on his
Wikipedia page and as a counterexample
if you look at my Wikipedia page there's
a bunch of different sections and lotted
lots of information on it so he says
there's political bias the right-wing
wiki pages are being stifled left-wing
wiki pages are being allowed so I get
this mesh's message from mark dice and I
assume he just wants my honest opinion
that were not sort of playing politics
or whatever and so I answer him honestly
and tell him that I'm trying to confirm
what it is that he is asserting here so
I wrote back to mark dice and I said I
want to make sure I understand the claim
your position is Wikipedia is liberally
biased on the evidence that you found a
few left-wing commenters who have pages
on the site but your page can't be
edited so I'm just trying to confirm
that we're on the same page about what
he's claiming and he responds to me in a
way that no one in this industry has
ever responded to me privately remember
these aren't public tweets these are
private messages he says oh just a few
how many more examples do you want never
mind
you're obviously severely blinded by
your bias
hash
Tagg liberalism find a cure so it's like
he's been totally set off and it's not
the way I talk to people really at all
but especially privately so I don't
respond in kind and he just keeps going
and again remember this is a private
conversation there's no audience to
impress here with what he's saying and
his next message to me is after I said
oh okay I was just trying to understand
the claim he says sorry I didn't know
you were that dense so at this point I'm
sort of like let me seriously look at
what he's claiming and I'll give him a
more detailed opinion and see how far
this thing goes so I look a little bit
more closely at what he's claiming about
Wikipedia and I write to him no problem
I don't care about out homonyms it looks
like your page was edited 20 times this
month I'm not seeing any edit rollbacks
which is common for patients that are
being censured or censored what should I
be looking at on the actual wiki page
that's concerning to you what does he do
he sends me a link to a Washington Times
article about this Wikipedia dust-up The
Washington Times of course is owned by
the crazy sung-yueng Moon cult Church so
I tell him what I think about that I
write back to him and I say The
Washington Times is owned by a crazy
cult so I think it's reasonable to
question it as a reliable source as far
as all the other stuff I think unless we
do an empirical analysis that's bigger
than a sample of a dozen it's tough to
make any general assessment about
Wikipedia's bias anything's possible but
in my experience with them there's just
way too much going on for them to even
try to micro-target at the level that's
being claimed don't really know what
else to say about it and then his final
commentary comes back in it's really sad
you can't admit the obvious that a group
of editors are zealously guarding the
page to prevent anyone from adding
anything that even hints that I actually
have a decent career and have wrote have
wrote several best-selling books quite
intellectually dishonest of you actually
but hey you're a liberal
so guess that should be I think he said
expected I'm unable to see that last
word there I then asked him hey Mark can
I share this with my audience and he
said sure so what have we learned from
this we've learned that it doesn't seem
mark dice it doesn't seem like mark dice
is playing a character in terms of who
he is on his show he genuinely seems to
believe at least some of the
conspiracies that he has put together
and he is not someone who is simply
going to be polite to colleagues in
private conversations as most people are
so I don't know if people find this
interesting if you've never heard of
mark dice maybe you don't even care
about this at all but I found it sort of
surprising because I have never had any
professional interaction with anybody in
this industry people on the Left who
disagree with me people on the right who
obviously disagree with me everybody has
been respectful and polite and sort of
collegial in a way that it would be nice
if in in in the sort of public sphere it
was more of a reality and Mark dice
apparently very very angry with me so
send me your thoughts curious to hear
what you think about it